[Music]
butcher what happened
my wife she's alive
what's holding the captive somewhere and
right now
we're in a little bit of trouble
are you [ __ ] with us
listen this is a [ __ ] mess
we're the most voiceless in the country
we've got soup terrorists
we got no superheroes hi
i'm stormfront who i'm the new girl
wonderful
oh god so what's your big plan
we'll take them fort there we go
in of course we're in
we blow it up in that air
more super terrorists will come
for all we know these maniacs could be
waiting for their chance to kill us all
who the [ __ ] are you i'm just trying to
help
really how but we can fight back
with an army of supermen millions strong
no don't be a [ __ ] laser my [ __ ]
tits
she's got a whole army of soups we got
still
i need more soup [ __ ] all right what do
we do
we can't just kill everyone that's
exactly what we're gonna do
oh great cool totally
okay you guys go ahead you guys go ahead
i'm good all right
hands in the air like you just don't
care
kill
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new boys season 2
trailer
so much wtf stuff in this to break down
so many easter eggs so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything
i will be doing videos for all the
episodes this season and as you can see
from the trailer footage it's
way way crazier than season one so we'll
just start at the beginning of this and
work through shot by shot and just do
easter eggs as we go along
but it opens with butcher at the end of
season one after homelander forcibly
took him to his ex-wife's house to show
him that she was still alive and just
throw homelanders
superboy lovechild with her in his face
like the thing that you've been mad at
me for this whole time
the reason why you want to kill me
because you think i killed your wife
didn't happen she's been alive this
whole time and she never told you
but then butcher later implies when he's
talking to the rest of the team trying
to rally them
get them behind his cause to go after
the seven and save his wife
he says he believes that vad has been
holding her captive this whole time
and that's why she didn't reach out to
tell him like when vogelbaum was
explained to homelander last season they
wanted to give his son the superboy a
chance at a normal life so that he
wouldn't be such a psychopath like
homelander
but because giancarlo esposito's
character is the one that's actually
running vaude american he's the one in
charge
i wouldn't put it past him to actually
legit hold her hostage in this situation
like you play by our rules and do what
we say and we'll make sure you're taken
care of
otherwise we'll kill you to keep you
from being a liability to homelander
because
bot's whole thing is that they want to
control homelander and control the
narrative around superheroes
they have this long-term goal to put
supers in the military
then put them in the white house and
that can't happen if things go
completely off the rails with
homelanders supposedly love child
so everyone's kind of waiting to see how
homelander is gonna deal with the
revelation that he actually has a son
now
there's some funny scenes later in the
trailer of him showing up later to show
his son teach him how to fly just
pushing him off the roof
classic 80s dad move like throwing your
son in a pool in order to teach him how
to swim
when the season begins though there is a
moderate time jump they might have just
a quick moment at the beginning to
address what happened at the end of last
season but then the actual season picks
up after a time jump
when butcher shows up he's been missing
for a while so there's a movie that they
made for the boys that they'll air after
the season two finale that'll explain
what he was doing during that missing
time period
then there's that big montage of the
boys simultaneously going on the run
because there's this outstanding warrant
for their arrest the whole world is
looking for them
then they discuss taking down the new
super villains that stormfront kept
talking about
like you see them with kimiko taking on
a bunch of other super power people
throughout the trailer
it's implied that they're quote unquote
superheroes but it sounds more like
people that stormfront and vaught are
manipulating to just help control their
narrative and get people more riled up
about supers in the military
remember the whole reason why vaught
even creates superheroes
is purely for merchandising and making
more money they don't care what the
superheroes do they don't even care if
they save people
and most of the superheroes themselves
aren't actually that good
at using their powers they're actually
pretty terrible remember the funny
opening scene from season two episode
one where he's talking to giancarlo
esposito about collateral damage he says
oh you know about 30 percent
as in 30 of the city will be destroyed
that they're going to be working in
there's a really big scene of huey just
freaking out inside the sevens lair with
this giant explosion
it's also probably associated with this
starlight scene where she's fighting
black noir and he's just giving her the
business
but it actually seems like her ability
is pretty powerful because she's able to
blast him and pin him up in the ceiling
remember the whole thing during season
two is that starlight is now
full team boys like you see her put
these glasses on in this dark jacket
like she's trying to go undercover
inside vaught
she's informing on the seven for the
boys giving butcher information about
what they're doing what their plans are
so they can help take them down and
accomplish their goal of saving
butcher's wife
and also dismantling the seven from
within
but black noir is kind of like the
sleeper cell inside the seven he's the
person that vaught uses on the dl
to take care of other super powerful
superheroes that go off the rails
and when there's a superhero out there
that doesn't do what vaught wants them
to do
usually they send black noir to kill
them this what that whole opening
scene was with him taking down that
quote-unquote new super villain that
homelander
secretly artificially created for the
very purpose of stoking people about
supers in the military
like okay we're done with him we don't
need him to do anything anymore so we're
going to send black noir to just put him
on ice
there's a really interesting scene of
the george washington picture being
sprayed with blood i also think that's
foreshadowing for later in the series
like you think about
president george washington of the
united states one of the episodes is
titled the bloody doors off and that
gets into the seven and vaught's
long-term plans to put supers in the
white house which is actually the very
end of the comic book story but here's
the thing the show has already been
renewed for season 3 so i'm assuming
that the plot of that particular episode
will be very different from the comic
book story
most of the episode titles here are
actually named from chapters in the
comic book but they're already changing
a lot of the comic book story so i'll
try to point out
some of the changes when i do episode
videos love all the footage of
homelander just lasering the crap out of
random people like you see him in this
cabin here it seems like he's going
after the boys and they maybe just miss
them and he's pissed off at this soldier
and that's why he's blowing him up
then we absolutely have to talk about
what's going on between homelander
and stormfront so you have a lot of
stormfront stuff early in the season it
looks like homelander is pissed off
about what she's doing like what the
hell
are you doing who the hell do you think
you are there are a couple reasons why
giancarlo esposito's character puts her
on the seven as the new member
she's really good at manipulating people
the way you see homelander do it during
season one like he's trying to get the
crowd riled up at that big rally
she's way better at that but homelander
isn't really in on
giancarlo esposito's plan so he doesn't
know exactly what's going on that's why
he's so pissed off at her like what is
going on this was supposed to be my plan
what are you doing
the way that aya cash talked about her
character she said that obviously he
hates her
at the very beginning but she slowly
wins him over and as you can see
they have this really weird sexual
energy between the two of them so it's
kind of like she's replacing stillwell
a little bit even though she's not a
figure of authority she doesn't wield
authority over him
but think about homelanders relationship
with stillwell and all the crazy weird
mommy issues that he had that was just
the creepiest relationship ever
now that's just kind of spilled over
into this kind of toxic relationship
where it seems like they just absolutely
get busy with each other no
idea why he has to laser the crap out of
her chest but she looks like she enjoys
it like they have some weird bdsm thing
going on between the two of them
so if you thought that season one was
messed up with all that stillwell
relationship stuff this just takes that
to the next level
there's a bunch more footage of
stormfront flying around using her
powers you actually get a better sense
for
how powerful she is she's not nearly as
strong as homelander but she has super
strength she can fly
she has lightning-based powers she's
sort of like a combination of shazam
at dc in the justice league and then
thor at marvel and the avengers she
comes from a team called payback in the
comics that's obviously meant to be a
reference to the avengers at marvel but
i don't know if they're going to give
her that backstory on the tv show we'll
just have to wait for the actual
episodes
but big reminder the season is going to
drop september 4th but they're airing
episodes a little bit differently
so the first three episodes are going to
drop friday september 4th i'll do a
video for that
but then all the rest of the episodes
will air once per week and i'm assuming
after the finale is when we're going to
get that boys short movie about butcher
so i'll do a separate video about that
too
but by the time we get towards the end
of the boys season we'll be getting
ready for the mandalorian season two
episodes
so if you're a big fan of giancarlo
esposito he's gonna be really huge
during the boys season two is kind of an
antagonist
and then also a big villain antagonist
during the mandalorian season too
in fact today he was actually busy
getting people hyped up about playing
with the darksaber during the
mandalorian season 2. so no worries i'll
talk about all that stuff when they
start dropping new mandalorian season 2
footage which will be really soon
everyone just let me know in the
comments what's your favorite part of
this trailer what are you most hyped up
about for the boys season 2
they've already dropped a couple really
big new boys season 2 trailers and video
clips you can click here to watch
all of those